in a pipe or tree to welcome everybody
to another episode of a genius brain
whoa
it's an OG cast date today I mean George
it's Okawa and I'm David slow and today
we have a very interesting topic so we
have a genius brain submission box and
then sometimes we just put our hand
inside and we pull it out and we say
what question do we have today from one
of our genius brain brainers pull that
[ __ ] out like a doctor give him [ __ ]
a baby out of a vagina
you got a what is that hook thing for
yourself back stupid [ __ ] car
accident but they've never been the same
I've never been the same is what is this
that was a crazy year man we were
burning out working crazy and at the
same time you had a car accident it was
so many to use car exits all backside my
life was going to trash gained a lot of
[ __ ] weight was very unhappy it was
it was a rough time man but but what
didn't you say I would do it all again
to be where I'm at today I think I could
do without the car accident
yeah I mean all these all these things
that happen happen for me I haven't even
had one injury as bad as yours well
maybe when I got kicked in the ribs but
that was it yeah you're actually pretty
brand [ __ ] knew you'd know I'd like
know sprained ankles know me a pain but
then I kind of like let it chill out
like I have plantar fasciitis and [ __ ]
like it says it's gonna take six weeks
to heal
what is plantar fascial because I had it
too before and it just it hurt when I
did like side to side I didn't really
ask what it was they just said you have
it so just chill oh but when you wake up
in the morning the this whole area
that's right here right or it feels like
needles inside yes so when I was doing
its when I first started training with
Nick and I had to do kickboxing yeah I
got plantar fasciitis yeah it's very
foot heavy a lot of footwork a lot of
that stuff they're straining it and then
your calves are tight and it's pulling
on it yeah and then after I lost a bunch
of weight and then um I kind of rested
for like a month
yeah and it went away yep so it's all
kind of goes I said was [ __ ] painful
that yeah cuz I got it first when I was
training for Spartan races
and doing martial arts so I'll run eight
miles and then I'll do kickboxing and
then some too much on my soles of my
foot you know yeah and then same with
recently when it came back you know I've
been training like two three hours just
like non-stop on my [ __ ] feet like
you know some boxing drills and stuff
and it came back and I got ding it was
everybody though
it's almost a question today oh yeah a
question oh my bad yeah got too much in
a training issue I guess this guy's name
is dar so so subbed are so so hey guys I
wanted to know how would y'all go from
he's a how jogo how'd y'all go from
introverted to extroverted I've
literally been pretty antisocial and
I've wanted / am starting to change that
a bit but I'm scared of social rejection
ooh
that's a very good one dude damn that is
good hey you know what some read new
research I heard is that people that
were extroverted earlier on in life once
they get older they tend to become
introverted and vice versa so
introverted people earlier on in life as
they get older they like they start to
open up and wanting to go out and it
switches you know what's interesting for
me is people assume that I'm extroverted
I am actually not I am introverted
you're you're you're what so I did that
myers-briggs over 10 Stu me because I
actually so interesting story when I was
younger my dad used to [ __ ] hate me
because he hated the fact that I hated
confrontation he also hated the fact
that it's because when there would be
times for me to speak up what I would
want or speak my mind I would never do
it and then I would harbor ill feelings
towards people or my parents when I
never would state how I felt I see right
number two I would I would say I was so
[ __ ] timid that I couldn't order food
like I could not order food because I
was it might have been fear of social
rejection or whatever at them small my
new possibility that I will [ __ ] up an
order if that's how things will work in
my head so
I think this down it would it would kind
of work like this where let's say I went
to a vid amis restaurant right and I
don't know how to pronounce something I
but I wanted to get that thing to eat I
wouldn't order it just because I would
be afraid of being in homes for you this
is how I like in high school like 1213
but so you wanted that food but you were
too scared too scared to ask for it yeah
so I'd be too scared to ask for it
because I don't know what it is or I
don't know what it's called I wouldn't
go out the way be like hey what is this
I wouldn't do that type of stuff right
and I just didn't like just putting
myself out there so being introverted
was my my go-to yeah I am still
introverted till this day if you guys
notice like even I do have a lot of
friends I guess quote-unquote but my
close friends are really just you guys
oh that's true who else do I kick it
with as much as you guys nobody and you
don't make new friends but you have a
lot of friends exactly they're like
childhood friends exactly oh so I'm
constantly making new friends exactly
you're you're the exact opposite of me
and even when I go to these social
situations yeah my first initial thing
is to just get on my phone stay in the
corner and not people talk to me I don't
feel weird about that either I don't
feel weird about being in a corner by
myself and having nobody talk to me I
actually prefer that it doesn't make me
feel too awkward anymore
but when I act like for example if I
have to go to these like social events
where I have to socialize I put on this
face it's something that I had to
develop it's something that my dad beat
out of me
beat the socialising you beat the
socializing in to me he goes you stop
being a [ __ ] weirdo and learn how to
play this a little better right so
before I go to these social events or
meetings I literally put on my game face
my manager has literally seen me do this
before he seen me go in and he's seen my
introverted self and he doesn't like it
and I was like oh is this a game that I
have to play with a lot of these
executives not a games per se because
it's still an extension of Who I am
yeah but I just have to be vulnerable
and open that side up to people who I
normally wouldn't off the job so I would
go in and then after sometimes when I
mean at these meetings and these are
people that I don't like which 99% of
the people that I have meetings with I
[ __ ] love but I'll come out and Abe
goes uh you went from smiling to nothing
he goes what happened
he goes I was like I [ __ ] him in like
those people she's like how did you do
that she goes you could never do that
before I was like well cuz I learned how
to play it better I've learned to
practice this I had it I to practice it
very [ __ ] well because it was it was
something that was hindering my life
yeah right for me first me something as
stupid is not to be able to order
[ __ ] food because I had social
anxiety yeah dumb yes when you look at
the grand scheme of things it's [ __ ]
stupid that's true you know what I mean
and that eventually started up to be do
it going doing stand-up yeah
joining challenging yourself yeah I
didn't even want to join choir when I
was a kid because I was afraid of people
calling me a [ __ ] like that was the
hot word back in the day yeah but then
after I said you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna join choirs that's what you want
to do you want to sing you want to get
yeah yeah so cuz what I hear from this
email is that you have a desire to want
to socialize yeah because a true
introvert is like they don't care yeah
so the word okay so I think that in
common terms too like they're the we
frequently confused introvert extrovert
with shy or outgoing yeah but that's not
the real definition the real definition
is introverts get overwhelmed by human
energy
yeah well extroverts thrive under human
energy and in the opposite happens like
extroverts when you when you when you're
kind of too isolated you get cabin fever
really fast yeah or when you're around
just one energy you start to get really
sick of that one energy yeah versus I
think introverts they want quality time
with a very few number of people that's
me yeah and it's just the way that we
recharge so I think when people see
someone that's outgoing and and talking
it's very easy to confuse them as an
extra like you like I was I thought you
were an extrovert but it it is confusing
because it's like yeah you you seem like
you're thriving with this energy but
what I realized is I never seen you that
much with new people or in an
environment with new people I've only
seen you with childhood friends us so
when in and when we go to events its
people that we already know because even
sometimes - I have to catch myself like
if let's say we're I'm training with a
bunch of people
like few people I don't know nick says
it goes do you look like you want to
[ __ ] them up dude really yeah he goes
you look like you want to beat the
[ __ ] brakes off oh I don't want to
beat the brakes off at the [ __ ] I
don't care about them yeah it's like so
when we spar they don't exist they don't
just all world so when we spar if you
hit me hard I'm gonna crack you as hard
as I can you know so it's like I don't
have that feeling of I care about you
yeah so like I don't yeah cuz I feel
when I go into these social settings and
there's a big group of people I'm it's
fun in the moment but afterwards I'm
[ __ ] drained and exhausted I feel like
that's how I get my energy and I'm like
let's [ __ ] go yeah that's why I
wasn't sure if Mike even sometimes like
am I good am I supposed to be a stand-up
comic because it's it's literally new
energy every time you know and it's
exhausting for me so after I do like two
or three shows back to back I'm [ __ ]
exhausted but comics they I think
they're extroverts because they thrive
on that [ __ ] they thrive on that new
interaction with people making people
laugh and true I don't really have that
thing I just like to connect with people
that I've that I've developed a certain
relationship with yeah this podcast is
brought to you by purple now my friends
my whole life I had been betrayed
betrayed I said I said betrayed by my
own bed the person that I leaned on
every night layed on in fact well purple
has changed my life number one there's a
few things about me that you guys should
know I sweats a lot in my sleep I'm a
very very hot man I run hot all the time
purple keeps me cool at night with this
rocket science technology my friends
that's right rocket science developed
the technology behind the purple
mattress it's firm and soft at the same
time it's something that you guys have
not experienced yet if you do not own a
purple mattress and because of purple
mattress I realize how important sleep
is in my life and how much I needed it
because I have been sleeping like a baby
ever since I've had a purple mattress
now check this out man there's a hundred
night risk-free trial if you're not
fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund that's insane
and it's also backed by a 10-year
warranty yes my friends you're going to
love purple and
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're already offering site-wide
just text brain to eight four - eight
eight eight the only way to get this
free pillow is the text brain - eight
four - eight eight eight that's B are AI
n two eight four eight eight eight
damn that that's a good observation yeah
I mean I think it all depends right like
in this kid's situation maybe he's just
shy but inside he's actually an
extrovert and he loves this stuff
because I feel like people don't know
who they really are and if they're
desiring something you know if they
desire human contact and all those
things he might be a closeted extrovert
oh do you know what that's yeah I kind
of see that too I think mmm that makes
sense because what you said earlier was
that introverts are probably happy being
not around you know they don't they
don't have the desire to go I need to
[ __ ] do this
yeah it's more like well because in your
situation it's like I want to sing but
to sing I have to be onstage yeah I want
to do comedy because I think it's funny
and I want to challenge myself but I
have to be onstage and do it right so
it's different and um it's funny cuz
that's what my dad said he was like I
should have chose a different career you
know like because I love music I love to
create and compose but I hate performing
I'm terrified and he's like and over the
years it never gets easier it still
drains me it's still scary I still feel
the same like butterflies so the real
thing about this thing is it's not that
you need to figure out how to be come an
introvert to an extrovert you got to
learn how to not be socially awkward
yeah that's that's the thing that you
really need help with that's like well
and you know what there's a lot of
people on this earth though to be honest
with you that are socially awkward and
they don't even know that they're
[ __ ] socially awkward yeah just they
don't [ __ ] know it they're out there
they're not self-aware it oh man there
are certain fans that I [ __ ] meet
that number one thank you for supporting
me and you really don't
but the social awkward level is really
really
[ __ ] you remember we got stop right here
at Glendale in the middle of us talking
to this group of fans that wanted to
take a picture
another group sauce and in the middle of
that wall we're taking a picture like
we're posing right they step in the
middle go hey can't we take a picture
with you and then they are handing the
camera to the I'm like we're taking what
is doing you just push these other human
beings aside man dude when we were at SN
foods there was a guy who Tim was
talking to a family and a little kid and
the guy literally steps in front of the
child he goes yo can I get a picture
since they're taking so long
it's like bro oh like seven year old kid
what's wrong with you a kid shut the
[ __ ] up yeah it's like yo come on bro
like you're socially [ __ ] right now
like how do you not know in this
situation that number one that's
disrespectful number two that's very
[ __ ] rude what's wrong with you man
it's like a cocktail of socially awkward
and nervous yeah yeah already [ __ ]
dumb to begin with then you bring the
you bring the [ __ ] I'm so nervous I
don't know what I'm gonna do and then
they just dudes they act you know a lot
of that social anxiety and being
socially awkward though does come from
overthinking a lot of situations
specifically when you meet somebody
you're you're always looking at the
negative and you're thinking about what
is gonna happen when I fall on my
[ __ ] face yeah and the reality of the
situation is is that sometimes when you
have these conversations you're not
gonna know what to say and you know
things will get awkward here and there
but you have to be willing to take those
chances and you're not gonna learn how
to navigate through a conversation
unless you actually try and do it it's
everything in life that I'm really
finding out specifically because it's
just Muay Thai yes it's all about the
[ __ ] reps baby yeah about repetition
repetition repetition repetition yeah I
just watched this TED talk about this
guy he's from China and he decided to do
100 days of rejection and one of his
videos went viral but he's recording his
experiences right and he'll he's kind of
funny he'll asked for like weird things
like he went to [ __ ] Krispy Kreme and
he asked for the donuts to be like in a
ring like the Olympics yeah and then
they actually did that for him
and he went up to a security guard at
his company and he asked him if he could
borrow a hundred bucks and like he would
obviously get no but it was just a
hundred days of like just doing
different things and getting rejected on
purpose so he would ask for ludicrous
[ __ ] yeah because he couldn't get over
this hump of fear of rejection fear of
failure and like he was once an
entrepreneur but failed because he had
opportunity but he had so many fears
that he wasn't making any moves and so
he realized like you know maybe I just
gotta go out there and get rejected
until rejections not scary anymore you
have to fail and adjust yes that's the
hard part right so there's another part
to these sometimes when you we give
these in these this advice people only
take the small part of it and they don't
take the full scope of things right so I
think you fail at things you you you
learn from your experiences then you
make adjustments right you can't keep on
tackling things the same way over and
over and over again like if you put
yourself out there and you had a couple
to say let's say this social anxiety
awkwardness comes from you wanting to
date somebody right you approach
somebody I know a couple of youtubers
right now two biggest losers I've ever
met in my life the way they approach
women they first what they do is they
ask them if they know if they if they if
they've seen them on YouTube right and
they they give them their phone and they
go look at all my videos a viral bit
yeah and look at my look at my videos
this is who I am and they get rejected
all the time and they haven't figured
out that that doesn't [ __ ] work the
[ __ ] losers right the two [ __ ]
biggest and then when they get rejected
they go oh they literally I've by the
way this is a story that I'm telling you
I'm not gonna say the [ __ ] names but
I've heard of this story because my
friend was actually hit on by one Oh No
right and they said the most
disrespectful things were I think I
think I know the same yeah we know who
these guys are and so they come up and
they meet her at a bar right and by the
way my friend is super [ __ ] cute
she's adorable yeah beautiful woman she
said that she's sitting there and mind
you she's [ __ ] sweet she's dope and
she's at the bar they come up he goes
this is the lie that they use they go
I couldn't help but notice your swag
from a distance and I had to just come
up and talk to you yeah that was the
opening whose swag anymore I don't
[ __ ] know and then yo girl your swag
was so was the line magnetic that was
the line for Batum that's how much she
was creepy only [ __ ] and that would
creep me out and then he goes yo have
you heard of us on YouTube and she goes
no not really
right she goes I haven't heard of you on
YouTube whatever right now but she kind
of knew who they were but right off the
jump it was already a terrible line
right and he's like yo this is who I am
ball about you should check us out this
is like I got oh maybe you've heard this
video it has like X amount of millions
of views so that's how they're trying to
impress women by showing you how they
are
that's the you might as like a [ __ ]
oil like rich billionaire that's like do
you want [ __ ] Louboutin I buy you
back yeah this is my Lamborghini outside
you have this I have five car you want
exactly side drive with me but [ __ ]
that's the same kind of [ __ ] but the
difference is he actually has a lot of
money that's true you know what I mean
he actually has the stuff to offer and
then afterwards she rejects him and he
goes whites because you don't like asian
guys or what Wow [ __ ] disrespect the
disrespect and number one you don't you
don't put it on asian people to why
you're socially awkward yeah you just
might be ugly yeah you might be [ __ ]
ugly and you also don't know how to
speak to women Wow disrespectful [ __ ]
yeah so you know that's the type of you
know there's that type of socially
awkward to right now and if you're
socially awkward by the way no amount of
[ __ ] money no amount of how ugly you
are is gonna surpass the fact that you
don't know how to be around people yeah
like you will find yourself being
rejected constantly because you don't
know how to talk to human beings it's a
skill that you have to develop and in
these people's cases too and I'm not
even fishing for these [ __ ] stories
people dislike these guys so much they
come they tell us these stories guys
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like I
why are people telling me this [ __ ] and
to straight up dude like this is how
they treat people yeah and so they
haven't learned and I keep hearing the
same stories about how they approach
women and how they talk to them and it's
they haven't learned so
that's another type of social
awkwardness that you have to really
learn from because if you keep doing the
same tactic and you keep blaming
everybody else for the reason why women
won't talk to you and and for these guys
cases too they're very successful people
online and they still can't get women to
talk them you know that's got to be
really bad I know it [ __ ] sucks so if
you already if you already viral and
it's like come on man like there's guys
with [ __ ] beater cars and no money and
they they're playing women and women are
paying for them exactly and I mean
that's not great and no but I'm just
saying like there's losers out there
that can date multiple beautiful women
yeah and I'm pretty sure you're not a
big of a loser as these dudes so um if
you are if you do feel like you're
socially awkward just number one assess
the situation understand what you want
out of a conversation and you know if it
takes time for you to just be prepared
for certain topics that you want to
speak about yeah then it then start with
that that's what I would do right so if
I know that I'm gonna go into the
socially because you were in your head a
lot as a kid
oh right so you could probably relate
well like what would would be the things
that you would do to prepare so one of
the things that I did was it I had to
change my mentality first I had to go
before we even get into the
specificities of specific actions that
you should do outside of just working on
yourself the first thing I did was I
told myself to shut the [ __ ] up because
I would prevent myself from talking to
people simply because I was too scared
so I knew over-worried
all were worried shut that [ __ ] down
first right after I shut that [ __ ] down
I went out and I put myself out there I
failed a lot and I [ __ ] feel I was
stuttering I got super [ __ ] nervous
like even ordering the food I remember
um this time I had to order I wanted
french fries at McDonald's I was like
super [ __ ] young and I went up in and
I was stuttering and I was super quiet
and I remember this because the person
couldn't hear what I was saying like
sweetie I can't hear what you're saying
and and I just froze and I didn't say
anything
my grandma who doesn't even speak
English came up and then she [ __ ]
orders for me
and as a kid I remember that and you had
stage fright a stage fright and I
remember I said a couple years after
that when I got older I had to be like
13 or 14 I looked back at that time and
I was like how sorry are you as a human
being that your grandmother who doesn't
even speak English how to order food for
you
she doesn't even have social anxiety and
she can't speak the [ __ ] language and
so I had to take myself out of the
situation say it's really not that big
of a [ __ ] deal bro it's not that big
of a deal and then when I started
getting into these circles and I started
having conversations with people I got
rejected a lot like people just didn't
like who I was and I had to learn how to
be okay with the fact that there's just
some people that aren't gonna vibe with
me yeah but if I continually put myself
out there eventually I'm gonna find
people that [ __ ] with me right and I did
it was like oh there was nothing wrong
with me in the first place it was that
that we just didn't match
well they just come from a different
world different thinking whatever yeah
and then you know I went through that
phase in high school where I try to be
something that I wasn't I try to be in
clucker here man you know I try to be an
anime nerd I wanted to be a thug I
wanted to be everything so I wanted to
be a part of all these groups but then
I'd later found out that I was just
wasn't being myself and then I kept on
trying to adapt to what other people
wanted so I kind of it kind of I kind of
got lost in all this [ __ ] so now that
I've learned to become quote-unquote
extroverted I started doing this thing
where I was emulating other people
instead of being who I was so first
things first tell yourself that shut the
[ __ ] up put yourself out there make
those mistakes get rejected and then
understand that that's just a learning
process to figure out who you are and
what I want and I would and I would tell
anyone that mistakes are fun like it's
it's literally really it's the only
thing you're risking is really your
pride or whatever it's just really
temporary yeah there's nothing real like
there's no real threat like it's it's
more to me it's scarier like before I'm
thinking about it then actually like
when it's happening yeah and if people
be like well you're extroverted yelling
they're like well I still get shy I
still get nervous I still know those
feelings but I guess maybe I've overcome
them really fast cuz I just jump into it
cuz I don't like that feeling of like oh
what if I just like I [ __ ] I'm the
kind of guy that just jumps and I don't
care what happens cuz I don't know like
I know that the feeling of anxiety and
nervousness is worse than just diving in
and letting it [ __ ] happened
you know I rather just make that mistake
yeah cuz it's too crazy for me like
especially if you spend hours of your
time just in that state of nervousness
look that's just that's a nasty feeling
this podcast is brought to you by
Vistaprint now people out there you guys
know I own my own businesses I'm talking
about from food ventures to even this
podcast and when I go to these mixers
and I'm trying to make connections with
people and I really do need people to
understand that number one I mean
serious business and number two I need
them to get my contact I use business
cards now the cool thing about
vistaprint is they create amazing
business cards I'm talking about
customized a lot of different color
choices we got templates we got
everything going on with vistaprint and
business cards for me anyways
has always been something that I've kept
in the back of my pocket when I do these
mixers because whenever I need someone
to get my information immediately I got
business cards ready to go now
with these cards you could choose
whatever style finish shape or paper you
like and get free shipping and because
you can pick the colors fonts designs
and images it means you can create
something as unique and compelling as
your business so if vistaprint wants you
to be able to own the now in any
situation so which is why our listeners
will get free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity just go to
vistaprint.com
and enter promo code brain for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity limited time offer own the
now at vistaprint.com promo code brain
you support our show when you support
our sponsors it sucks - and I think that
when we get into those spots it feels
like it's going to be forever and it's
yeah everything always feels like in a
[ __ ] eternity it's like when you get
into if you've ever been to a car crash
like when something happens and your car
spinning out of control
that those two seconds feel like 10,000
hours that's true and that's what social
anxiety feels like for people who don't
have it is that when you have a
conversation and you're and you put
yourself out there and the moment the
conversation
goes wrong you start to feel like your
whole body's about to crumble like your
whole existence is crumbling and that's
all you can focus on as I kick yourself
out of this conversation things are
getting awkward why why are things
getting awkward this is very weird
you're stupid you're stupid and you
start you start to beat yourself um
while you're in the moment and that's
the hard part that you're gonna have to
get out of you know because it's it's
it's all temporary dude yeah all that's
just temporary and even here's the
bigger picture too so let's say in fact
you made an ass out of yourself right
and if somebody you don't know you don't
ever have to see that person again yeah
if you don't want to right what's gonna
[ __ ] happen I don't know life is
short do people forget people forget you
in an instant man if famous people get
forgotten when they've done amazing
things what do you think is gonna happen
with you people will forget about that's
true just keep going just keep keep
moving on one thing I did to get over
cuz I'm I feel like I was always okay in
groups or like meeting new people or
whatever but the big thing for me was
talking to women like growing up I feel
like that was scary I can remember
asking this one girl for my for a number
and I didn't even prep and then I was
like oh crap she was gonna give it to me
but my dumb ass didn't have a pen or
anything so then her I ran up and I
asked everybody for a pen and I gave it
to her and her friend was standing there
like yo are you nervous and then I'm
like woah and then I got this pen and I
gave it to her and then she's like
where's the paper and I'm like oh yeah
and then I'll sit and she's like write
it on your [ __ ] hand and I was like
oh okay and I [ __ ] did it and I was
like make it big so it doesn't wipe off
and then she wrote her number and in my
hand was shaking she's like oh my god
you're shaking
that's so cute and I was so [ __ ]
embarrassed man when I got her number
and we talked like every single day and
I'm so glad that I went for it because I
would see her like walking around high
school like all the [ __ ] time and I'm
like man I want her so bad you never
ended up getting together but I think
that that that really got me to feel
like man I don't want to be nervous
around women cuz like it makes me feel
like so stupid and it's a bad first
impression yeah so what I did was
I just started talking to women I was
attracted to but places where they had
to talk to me like at the mall like if
they're working at Foot Locker or
whatever or anywhere I'm just like she's
a cute girl like I would I wouldn't do
the whole pickup guy thing because that
was just a little too weird for me but
you want to show them your YouTube I
wouldn't be like hey man this is Who I
am have you heard of just kidding films
you should do some research on me first
because I'm gonna let you know how
awesome I am well we try well in high
school we would go to the mall and do
that whole thing and you try to talk to
girls and stuff that are your age or
whatever right but then like over the
years I just want I just I just wanted
to get better at conversation and just
like having small talk and not being so
nervous because this person was
attractive yeah so I talked to men women
like everyone and then when it came down
to a hot girl I was just like oh [ __ ]
but then I would just talk to them and
I'm like well you know what I'm not
trying to get with them I'm not trying
to like be with them I'm just trying to
like talk about nothing and I realized
that the only reason why I was so
nervous is because half half of the time
I'm just thinking about [ __ ] them and
if I'm gonna get that so like your minds
not in the right place cuz you're
already like if you don't get it then
it's already a loss in your head so
you're nervous of the loss yeah but if
you think about it as just like oh I
just want to exchange a sentence with
this person yeah and then cool like oh I
made a smile cool whatever we just and
then after after that it just doesn't
even matter how hot they are you just
talk to them like whatever you know what
the best I think the the best thing that
I ever did that actually kind of helps
me out as an adult now especially when
it comes to talking to women oh not that
it matters anymore Muriel but is that I
learned to talk to women like you don't
want anything from them yeah girls are
very intuitive people like they know
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] thirsty
ass [ __ ] yeah like they can they can
[ __ ] sense that and when your
motivation for to talk to a girl is
simply because you just want to [ __ ]
them girls can sense that [ __ ] right and
if something does develop like I think
for me too like it's now has developed
into the point now where I can literally
come up to a girl that I've had a
conversation with I could look them
straight in the [ __ ] eye
you're very beautiful yeah but that's
just it
there's no see you later yeah there's no
like there's no like hey you are you
[ __ ] fine like there's nothing that
is what I just I just have to let you
know that your swag was so it's like
that situation right it's disgusting
like I can literally look it's a look at
a girl I just works for you just let me
know that but uh if situations like I
could take look at a girl and say wow
you're very you're very beautiful and
just leave it at that it's just because
that's how I feel that's what I see and
that's what it is I could do the same
for a deuce I meant you are a handsome
looking [ __ ] guy yeah but there's no
weirdness to you you don't have that
like I'm trying to [ __ ] everything
energy yeah right or like I'm so
desperate I need to stick my [ __ ]
dick in somebody because I'm a virgin
energy like that's just weird [ __ ]
energy and I think I wish I knew this
younger too because I think I'd be like
way better with relationships and women
and stuff like that if I understood
energy and myself yeah and a lot of
people just don't get that yeah they're
especially guys guys are too [ __ ]
logical everything's like robotic right
like what might help is like sports yeah
or doing music or doing art but focusing
on how you feel because if you're
nervous and anxious
she'll sense that yeah not just women
but like in a group like if you want
more confidence at the workplace if
you're hanging out with your friends you
want to be heard like you gotta have you
gotta check your energy and what you're
projecting out there yeah yeah yeah and
that's my guess is easier said and said
than done for most people but you know
you're not gonna know unless you [ __ ]
try man repetition repetition and we
made plenty of mistakes I was watching
this one podcast with you know Dan
Bilzerian yep he was on he was he was
being interviewed and then they're like
how do you do it like how do you talk to
all these girls how do you whatever and
he goes oh I stopped
women so his whole thing was like he was
once that person that was super nervous
around girls right so he started just he
said every time I saw a superhot girl I
would just start a conversation and he's
like and he's like a thousand times out
of a thousand he's like I'm pretty much
getting rejected but he's like at the
grocery store at whatever at the club
we're just talking and talking and
talking and he goes and after a while
like I feel comfortable talking to
everyone right yeah and then so he
doesn't have the thirst energy and he
says that when he started just partying
and having fun and just attracting fun
he attracted people that want to have
fun and then he would take all these
cool photos with all these hot models
and that's when it really started to go
high for him because all these other
he's like there's something crazy with
hot women like if how women see other
hot women with you they all want a piece
hmm so it makes you hotter yeah and he
says I don't even [ __ ] do anything
they just all want to be in my photos
and all the parties III I remember
somebody telling me that Dan Bilzerian
they go oh how much do you pay these
girls he says like I don't [ __ ] pay
them yeah are you crazy he goes I only
want to be around women if they truly
want to be around me yeah he goes I'm
not gonna pay anybody any money to do
this then a lot of them are his
girlfriends yeah so the way he's he said
it is like he's like well in our
relationships it's all about honesty and
he's like we'll probably be with each
other for like three months at a time
but he's like it's okay if they have
boyfriends or whatever and he's like
maybe in the LA fake world that they're
in that's very refreshing because he'll
tell them like I slept with this many
people this week complete honesty a
thousand percent so then when the girls
hear that they're like what cuz
everyone's got like side lovers and fake
lovers and everyone's cheating and in
that world you know and then he says
that's all he he's dating them and yes
it's interesting it's true though
because I think this is like a Hollywood
thing that maybe a lot of people don't
really believe yeah and I could say this
and you probably won't believe it until
you're a part of this the
realm but it's almost more common that
people cheat them they don't and oh yeah
having a stable relationship is like
weird yeah yes it's it's weird like I'll
have a conversation with a couple of
dudes and they're just like yo so like
so who are you [ __ ] around with when
you were touring and I'm like nobody
like what you mean that no matter what
you mean nobody can say bro like the
[ __ ] but you get like [ __ ] thrones you
want you just you know take one down as
they would say and I'm like oh so this
is the common thing I'm the I'm the
outsider yeah I was like oh okay I
didn't know that and that's not me
putting judgment on them because if
that's a mutual agreement that they have
with their partners and that's that's
what it is but for me I guess or for all
of us it's like oh that's not the norm
yeah that's not the norm like it almost
makes me feel like I'm the one being
done like I'm not taking this
opportunity or some [ __ ] it's like this
just feels weird it feels very weird
it's either I'm single and I'm just
having fun and I'm [ __ ] around or I'm
with someone and like my dick belongs to
one yeah I got one giant dude too much
to think about anyways like if you know
like I don't know man I it's like if I'm
in relationship mode like my mind is
just more serious yeah and it feels like
everyone's a waste of time
I kind of want to would love to bring
somebody on this podcast that is
somebody who has a stable person and
then they have a bunch of side chicks
right like if they have an open
relationship with that person like what
that's like
yeah and what it feels like because for
me how I see it as is a big headache
cuz it's hard to deal with one person's
emotion having to deal with multiple
people's emotions it's [ __ ] difficult
well I think if everyone understands the
arrangement like let's say the side
people yeah they know they're just well
where's that [ __ ] then I think that's
fine
because that's kind of cool right if you
think about it like you have your you
have your partner and your partner's
fine with you it's almost like watching
porn because it's just a sexual thing
like or just a person that's also a
friend that you might [ __ ] from time to
time but you're not necessarily
romantically close with them Tugg ice
speaking of but I think there's always
feelings that get caught so that's
what's weird to me I saw this episode of
this play boys swingers or something
this was he [ __ ] a couple years ago
or something I forgot when this [ __ ]
came out but there's when I was like
surfing through partnership and I was
looking up like I think it spurred from
a conversation that we had on Jake Kane
use one of my porno explanation I think
we were talking about what what if porn
had just better storylines yeah like
real production and so playboy does like
real TV shows and this was a reality TV
show about people who swing and the one
episode that I clicked on was [ __ ]
hilarious
it was it was an episode where this girl
had fantasy of [ __ ] other men right
so it's the swing but this other dude
arguably very unattractive and very
[ __ ] nervous and it first started off
as them swinging together they were
[ __ ] around and this girl's getting
[ __ ] by this big old black dude and
she's loving it right and the other
dudes supposed to be [ __ ] by the other
girls too right but he's he in the room
he's in the room so it's a orgy it's an
orgy but I think the other two girls
that were there didn't really find him
attractive so they left so it was just
him in the room watching his wife
getting [ __ ] oh so he didn't get his
dick sucked or anything and then
afterwards they have a talking header
interview and he's just like yeah I felt
a little weird he's just basically
watching this guy [ __ ] his wife and it's
not an orgy anymore exactly so just what
do you call it like a cuddle yeah I
don't think that's what the guy signed
up for this is a funny [ __ ] show but
then I saw a couple other episodes and
most of them aren't like that most the
time was just like [ __ ] but look a
[ __ ] different turn yeah but that
episode was probably the only good
episode because it was his guy just
think you're super [ __ ] awkward
because other times like I watched
another episode where you know the guy
was watching his wife get it [ __ ] but
he'd liked that [ __ ] you can tell he's
enjoying it but this [ __ ] looked
like he was in anguish yeah but Playboy
I don't know what it's called maybe
somebody could write in the comments
just like swinging swing swinger what's
going on because I know Hugh
have died oh that's right I don't know
who's like running that [ __ ] and I don't
know I feel like Playboy's Matt lost its
magic like these to be like ooh playboy
now I'm just like yeah well remember
back in the day or a few years back they
were going to do editorial without nudes
they're like yeah that was weird
yeah they said we're gonna step away
from that we want to be real content I
might shut the [ __ ] up what do you mean
real kanji some titties they went
through some controversy too cuz they
were posting up a gay dude oh really
yeah because I don't know I I don't know
who took over the Playboy like brand and
Instagram and all that but yeah they
were posting like a gay guy in lingerie
and then everyone was like yo that's not
what they signed up for yeah we're
straight man yeah like we want to see
women yeah that I mean that well first
of all that doesn't make any sense not
on a political standpoint but it's
called Playboy so it's for men to watch
women like heterosexual you yeah and
they also have Playgirl for women to
watch so why would you put that in the
photo I really don't know why they did
that because well they were they were
arguing that like Hef always was LGBTQ
like kind of support start the LGBT
queue version of your Playboy exactly
you know that women so so they're saying
like because Hef was always like
protecting gay rights and all that stuff
they wanted to celebrate it with a with
a gay model for Playboy but then a lot
of people were like but ok we get that
but we're not getting subscribing and
and and we're not you know viewing all
these photos to look at men that's like
signing up for a [ __ ] butcher box and
saying I like vegetables and then you
get exact and then you get a box full of
vegetables to cite that what the [ __ ]
that's not what I subscribe that's great
I love vegetables too I'm trying to buy
meat here yeah yeah but it to me I was
like that's kind of [ __ ] weird and
then like I mean not the gay model part
being weird but it's just like we're a
straight men well that's just everybody
trying to high hop on that train of
everything is based on money you know
and yeah you know when you when you look
at companies - or Whoopi
we'll have to realize that I realized
later on just because we know we're in
this business is that these media
companies they're not doing things to
make a political standpoint they're not
doing things to just be like hey this is
what I truly stand for you know to a
certain extent yes but their other part
of its money it's because it's
profitable yeah it wasn't profitable do
you think that that as an editorial
magazine would have done that
yeah and they wouldn't have right
because they would have just been you
know too hot for TV or too hot to touch
right and they would leave it alone and
some of this stuff makes me wonder
though cuz like the gay community is
actually a very small percentage of the
population yeah so when things like um I
don't know like when Ron Tomatoes is
overly left-leaning and gay rights and
then like they kind of manipulate it and
you know how the whole Dave Chapelle
thing is like zero percent is because
the people that are that are doing the
voting in [ __ ] right yeah well the
people that are putting in the
submissions and their critics well we
all know just from being on the space
that people who are angry speak louder
than people who are happy because when
you're happy you have nothing to really
talk about but then when people who are
upset they're gonna be very vocal about
it because they have something to say
when everything in your life is going
right and you are in an accepted group
but what's there really to talk about
right like talking about white bread all
day who the [ __ ] cares just [ __ ]
white bread but when when you are upset
about something and you have a platform
to that that'll get attention of course
they're gonna get louder that's like the
same thing with YouTube comments people
who are inherently just angry people in
sales yeah they're gonna be the first
ones to write stuff to start [ __ ] up not
to say that's what the LGBT community is
I'm just giving the example oh you're
upset the loudest minority the less
angriest minority yeah they're gonna be
the one that's going to be heard the
most yeah so yeah that's pretty crazy
man yeah when we when we don't want that
I think that was for us too was like the
the hardest thing for us to do when I
when I started doing YouTube was to
really filter out bad comments and to
understand that some people just say
things just to say things and that when
you it's okay to respond that's the
thing I don't understand what people go
you be the bigger person David don't
know this is my house I
[ __ ] and respond when the [ __ ] I wanna
do it what that's the weird they may go
be the bigger person I don't want to be
and it's gonna know is that the bigger
person I don't know but it's how I see
it is this when you come on Instagram
Twitter or my YouTube page
guess what take off your shoes you and
an Asian household [ __ ] and it's my
rules so I choose to respond back and
it's not like I'm giving and I will say
this I have been more active about
responding to positive comments than
negative comments now which you guys
were right that why should I give
attention to people who hate me when
people who are adamant about supporting
me to get your attention they deserve
that type of attention too yeah however
when they come [ __ ] in my household they
pull their pants down and they lay a
Dookie right in the middle of the floor
i'ma grab their face and shove it in it
well what if they're just doing that to
get your attention because they know
that that's sometimes they do that
though they go man do I just wanted you
to respond back to me yeah like you
stupid son of a [ __ ] you got me I just
[ __ ] joking around
yeah some of them they just like this
one Korean guy I actually have it saved
on my phone that [ __ ] dumbass that
said that your yeah disgrace to Korean
people what is it what is that gonna
happen is to like a when or when you
have it this is what he said like you
have a child and it comes up daddy why
you cursing so much daddy why you can
reaso me do know this is him ha me but
it's like in Korean pop - why you curses
so much daddy I used to be used to be my
hero sir oh I dunno why are you cursing
so much in huh I love how you imagined
that whole scenario down for you he
wrote a whole scenario about me being a
father and then I looked up his YouTube
it's him in his office it's just him
sitting at his office going so decent my
office oh this is where I work and this
is my pen is my pen
I like a ballpoint pen because it's a
smooth on a piece of paper you [ __ ]
loser
he's like trying to be like kids don't
follow this man he's an evil man I'm
like bro you need to just die another
little [ __ ] yeah you probably doesn't
he's another literal [ __ ] bro we
should we should come up with what we're
for these people yeah literal [ __ ]
pretty good yeah these little [ __ ]
are so weird man and it's so weird that
he would come on to a space to write
this whole diatribe about morale
crazy people create angry people they're
the they're the loudest people man yeah
and then people were just cracking up
because I was just going back and forth
with him and that's good content though
yeah why shouldn't you talk [ __ ] back to
him it becomes an inside joke exactly I
just got a comment the other day where
somebody was like it was that old
classic comment of dude you're not black
it's like oh my god I had no [ __ ]
idea I wasn't good I had no [ __ ] clue
I wasn't black I had no [ __ ] idea you
dumb [ __ ] I checked the girl out of show
because she said she asked that during
the Q&A she was like I have a question
why does David think she's black oh why
does David think he's black and I'm all
like what the [ __ ] and I looked at bar
and I'm all like do you not understand
that Asians don't grow up only in white
neighborhoods and they can grow up in
black neighborhoods or Mexican
neighborhoods and then she was like
shocked yeah and I was like yeah I was
like you [ __ ] 88 in a black beauty
supply store where do you think he
learned English yeah that's my first
interpretation of English was in a
predominantly black it's God that shit's
gonna stick with you same with me like I
don't have perfect grammar and I don't
enunciation like white folks you know
like and this is a big this is a huge
[ __ ] improvement from what I used to
[ __ ] sound like yeah but it's it's
like you know the whole American
experience is different its regional
it's it's it's cultural it's there's
just so much to it and it there's really
it's difficult to act black unless
you're an Asian guy that grew up in a
white suburb and all of a sudden you
listen to hip-hop and then you go extra
far with what he had you know and then
on top of that to just to bring it down
to earth when you see Asians in
Australia and in the UK and they have an
Australian UK accent do you say oh what
are you trying to pretend to be so so in
that case - would you would you prefer
that I walk around a hetero so my name
is okay but it's uh cuz I grew up in
Korea like what the [ __ ] did you expect
I'm a just today we are cooking with dog
okay like what what
you want an Asian yeah like what do you
want for me I understand when there's
like a certain level of inauthenticity
right when somebody comes up and they
start front and like they're not who
they are right cuz we've seen that
before I've seen it constantly man Asian
guys that grew up in white neighborhoods
that think that you know that's really
acting black right there yeah well he's
trying to be like hood when nobody cares
bro just be your [ __ ] self
nobody gives a [ __ ] so I understand that
stuff right but even and the fact that
that person would even say that I'm
quote-unquote talking black or a hood or
whatever because those two words are not
synonymous by the way the the the
annoying thing is is that that alone
shows that you never grew up around a
single black person because I don't you
know yeah I don't I don't know like I
don't it's like it's like a small little
smidge of it just like a little twang to
it but it's not so that's the odd part
when I hear about this [ __ ] this is
actually more of like a sacramental
accent like Sal Vicki she's trying to
act like that girl's gross-looking mill
man that [ __ ] she got she can't close
her mouth when she speaks what the [ __ ]
is wrong with her oh I feel like shorts
all I was like yeah yeah y'all [ __ ]
midgets out there doing that y'all tie
around here but I gotta stand right here
you know y'all were y'all you're hanging
[ __ ] I'm getting stacks I'm making that
shit's real quick you don't shine y'all
jealous because I got my nails down my
hair dear right now and she's like a
mouth breather - oh yeah [ __ ]
disgusting man I don't know if it was
her but another or a white girl that
looks like her but there was this one
girl [ __ ] Twitter right now it's
going around she's like I got both
[ __ ] a pump that a Glock man will
pump me - clown clown will [ __ ] when
I got more pomp than a Glock 9 and
that's on a pier [ __ ] and I'm
like what the [ __ ]
people are crazy man the Internet allows
people to be whoever they want cuz
they're just picking and choosing now
what neighborhood or whatever they want
to rep yeah because it because before
you were a reflection of where you're
from and now it's like I want to be a
reflection of what I see on the Internet
yeah like we're just Sims yeah literally
people are playing Sims in real life now
that's a good way to put it dude
are playing [ __ ] Sims they get to
pick and choose their their character 10
like a [ __ ] it's so hard to do
that though I don't understand why
people want to do it I don't know I feel
like it's like you know like back in
high school we just I'm a breakdancer
today and a skater tomorrow and then
that's right but it's like kids have the
Internet and they're doing their high
school [ __ ] just online and these that
they haven't been able to grow out of it
and that's a big part of um like not
knowing your identity just to grab it
back to this guy yeah you're probably
seeing a lot of stuff that other people
are doing and you're not comfortable in
your own skin because you're not taking
that time to develop who you are what
you want mm-hmm so you're seeing you the
grass is always greener on the other
side so you're seeing what somebody else
has maybe and you're saying oh they're
extroverted I want that life but maybe
on the other foot on the other side
maybe you're you're an introvert and
there's something wrong with that
yeah just rule of thumb is just do
people overwhelm you and then you need
to recharge alone or do you need to be
around people and you thrive and and so
extrovert doesn't mean like you're
outgoing and talkative and all that
stuff
there are extroverts out there that just
like the presence of people I got a
buddy who's a hardcore extrovert but he
doesn't talk much and he's kind of shy
but he's got he's always with a ton of
friends yeah he's going to vacations
with 30 people like [ __ ] tons of but he
doesn't say [ __ ] nah but he's like loves
that energy and he's always out always
doing things yeah man he's the mouse
mouse extroverts what the company is the
corn and yeah I know a few people like
yeah ray - yeah ray is somebody who
doesn't talk a lot yeah but Ray is
always down to come out and kick it in
chill hmm so he's puppy like an
introvert extrovert - he's cool being by
himself but he likes being around people
he might yeah makes sense all right guys
well that wraps this episode of the
genius brain podcast we talked a lot
about introvert extrovert putting
yourself out there how not to be a loser
a [ __ ] loser that walks up the girls
and basically calls them [ __ ] because
they don't like Asian guys when they
really just don't like them as human
beings but other than that don't be
trash guys be awesome be more like me
and Joe you know what I mean just openly
trashy human beings that understand that
the best policy yeah well you guys could
catch this on Spotify stitch or iTunes
remember make sure when you're on iTunes
give us that five star review because we
want to climb climb to the top I do
believe that this is one of the best
podcasts out there because we could talk
about anything and everything and we're
here to accompany you every day for the
rest of your life we're gonna keep doing
this singing very much for your loyalty
yep and make sure you guys I have a
personal patreon and Joe has his Jenkin
news
JK news patreon make sure you guys check
that off you guys want to hear just
unfiltered content and also uh the Jamal
and Academy yeah join jamali and
academy.com I might do something on
introvert/extrovert too I think that'd
be great alright shall see y'all next
time